bonjour à toutes et à tous est ce que ça
vous est déjà arrivé de vous retrouver
face à un tableau et donne absolument
pas savoir où regarder tellement de
détails dans ces moments là on est tenté
de penser bon non mais vraiment je m'y
connais pas assez je sais pas vraiment
où regarder parce que bon mois et l'art
mineur figurez vous que votre regard de
néophytes quant à prendre autant aux
chercheurs que celui des experts et
grâce à un savant mélange d'informatique
de sciences humaines et d'histoire des
arts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait longtemps que les chercheurs se
questionne sur la réception des oeuvres
d'art ou le regard du spectateur ce post
il se regarde un reptile en fonction de
l'âge de la formation du contexte dans
lequel se trouve le spectateur alors
certes on a déjà eu recours à des
questionnaires ou à l'eye tracking au
culot mais tri dans la langue de molière
s'il vous plaît mais ces deux procédés
et présente plusieurs limitations
le questionnaire nécessite un recours au
langage qui est plus limitée chez
l'enfant et plus expert chez l'historien
de l'art par exemple quant à la et
tracking
il ne tient compte que de l'endroit où
les yeux se posent sur l'oeuvre sans
savoir si le spectateur regarde vraiment
cette zone tout en lui attribuant du
sens où s'il des fleurs simplement du
regard je veux dire on a déjà tous
regardé une chose tout en pensant à un
autre et si je mangeais un brownie le
sociologue mathias blanc lui a choisi
une solution alternative l'utilisation
du tracé armée de tablettes tactiles les
spectateurs sont invités à indiquer à
l'aide de traits de poing et de ronds
les éléments du tableau qui attire le
regard et qu'ils estiment important
exit la barrière sociale du langage ce
questionnaire est entièrement visuel
puisque c'est à partir d'une
reproduction du tableau que les
spectateurs s'exprime le nom de ce
formidable je joue analytique l'iconique
analysis toolkit une piccone cats pour
les intimes et croyez-moi iconique at ça
change tout prenez par exemple la
réunion musicale des frères le nain
beaucoup de spectateurs se montrait
perplexe quant au titre du tableau qui
ne correspondait pas à ce qu'il évoquait
chez eux cet intitulé il a été donnée
par des experts bien après la
réalisation de l'oeuvre
en se basant sur une interprétation très
savante mais pas unique
en effet les relever des traces et
montre que les spectateurs non experts
eux y voient plutôt une scène de
fiançailles
cette interprétation elle est loin
d'être incohérente elle est même tout à
fait plausible et elle permet d'engager
un dialogue très intéressant entre le
savoir experts et le
gare néophytes bien sûr pour en arriver
là il faut analyser une quantité
astronomique de tracé afin d'obtenir des
statistiques icône aux métriques
exploitables il faut donc faire
intervenir un brin magie ou
d'informatique en l'occurrence on peut
ainsi en apprendre beaucoup sur la
manière dont roger cadres supérieurs
féru d'histoire de l'art venu seul au
musée regards d'une oeuvre des frères le
nain et savoir en quoi sa manière de
voir le tableau diffère de celle de
lucie 10 ans venus en visite scolaire
avec toute sa classe en superposant les
différentes races et on obtient ainsi
une carte de chaleur ou les zones les
plus chaudes correspondent à celles où
le nombre d'interactions était le plus
important
on peut ainsi comparer les résultats
entre un groupe ayant été sensibilisés à
l'histoire de l'art est un groupe
n'ayant pas reçu de formation
particulière dans le domaine
prenez par exemple cette allégorie de la
justice signée jean baptiste vie car les
néophytes se sont focalisés sur l'aspect
violent de la scène avec des tracés
autour du club et du bébé suspendu
pendant ce temps là un groupe ayant reçu
des leçons sur le sujet et informer sur
ce qu'est une allégorie s'est concentré
sur les mains de salomon qui posé sur
son coeur est tendu vers l'avant
symbolise la justice iconique est contre
toute attente y compris celle de son
créateur mathias blanc se révèle avoir
des retombées dans le champ de la
pédagogie en effet savoir comment les
publics observent les oeuvres d'art
permet au musée de mieux adapter leur
scénographie afin d'optimiser
l'expérience et la réception artistique
vraiment c'est là dessus que tu te
focalises pour répondre notre allégorie
de la justice un musée pourra choisir
par exemple d'installer un cartels
explicatifs afin de signaler aux
spectateurs la symbolique derrière la
gestuelle de salomon ce type de
dispositif permet d'adapter le discours
muséal à différents types de spectateurs
ce qui est essentiel car le sens et
l'interprétation d'une oeuvre d'art ne
sont pas affichés il évolue avec le
temps en fonction de celles et ceux qui
la regardent
en retour les regards néophytes peuvent
aussi beaucoup pour m'apprendre aux
experts donc la prochaine fois que vous
ne serez pas quoi regarder dans un
tableau dites vous que les conservateurs
ont autant en apprendre de vous que vous
deux et attend mais comment on fait pour
le monochrome blanc
abbas et surtout de suite si tu
débarques avec malevitch ça résonne
noircir le tableau
si la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner et allez faire un tour sur
la chaîne dawn art